-You are one of my oldest,
dearest friends.
And one of my heroes, both of
our heroes is Jerry Seinfeld.
And you did "Comedians in Cars"
this year,
which I was so excited about.
How was that experience for you?
-It was great.
Now, me and Jerry are friends,
but it's a new friendship.
-Yeah.
-And he's 65 and a billionaire.
-So it's hard to navigate
where he's like, "Text me."
I'm like, "Okay."
So I'll text him,
and it's sort of --
I'm cautious. Texted him.
I was coming in yesterday,
so I texted him on Monday.
Said, "Hey, going to be
in the city tomorrow.
Me and our mutual friend John,
going to get some coffee
if you want join us."
He doesn't text me back
for, like, a day,
which is terrifying and hurtful
because if a normal person
doesn't text you back, fine.
Jerry not texting you back --
you can picture in your head
from the sitcom of him
looking at his phone
and going like,
"Neal Brennan, he's not
important to me."
[ Laughter ]
So he eventually texted me back
last night,
said, "Sorry
I couldn't make it."
And then he sent me
a YouTube clip
which was just clips of him.
[ Laughter ]
Which was him being like,
"I couldn't make it,
but this is the sort of things
I would have said...
[ Laughter ]
...had I shown up."
[ Applause ]
Oh, good. All right, good.
Good.
I'm going to start doing that
where I'm going to go,
"Hey, I can't make it
to your wedding,
but here's a clip of me
on George Lopez's talk show
from 2012."
-I thought it was very nice.
I enjoyed the episode
a great deal.
You have a dog, and he brought
dog treats for the dog?
-He brought dog treats.
I'm sure he went to the store
and got them.
He brought dog treats.
He bought Ben & Jerry's
beef jerky, right?
Which you know dogs love.
So he brings -- My dog --
-Dogs love brands.
-Yeah, they love branding.
Now, my dog loved the beef jerky
that Jerry gave him,
but it gave him
what is known in the business
as diarrhea.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-So I can't give him
those treats anymore.
I give him other treats.
So now when I give him treats,
he looks at me the way
comedy audiences
have been looking at me
for a decade,
which is,
"You're no Jerry Seinfeld."
[ Laughter ]
Which is painful. Yeah.
Yes! Yes!
-I have enjoyed over
the years --
I like talking to you
about your family.
You come from
a very large family.
-How's your mother?
-How's my mother?
My mother is very good.
-Great.
-Yeah, she was very happy.
I had to call her yesterday
with a question about --
my mother was a French teacher,
a middle school French teacher.
-Of course.
-I had a French question.
And she was thrilled.
-What was the question?
-We just wanted --
Amber Ruffin does that piece,
"Amber Says what?"
And we wanted the French "what."
And we wanted to make sure it
was "quoi" and not "quelle."
-Great.
-Simple question.
-Yeah.
And it makes your mom
feel useful.
-Oh, yeah, she'll wonder
why she didn't get paid.
[ Laughter ]
-How old's your mom?
-She was born in '48.
So uh, a hundred.
-70. Yeah.
My mom's going to be 85.
I'm, like, the youngest of ten.
Long story.
So she's at the age now --
every time I talk to her,
she tells me --
it's always Irish women --
who died and who fell in town,
of her friends.
-Those are the only two options?
-Mrs. McGwiggen died,
and Mrs. O'Reilly fell.
[ Laughter ]
That's generally how it goes,
and it is interesting to say,
"Oh, good, she didn't die."
Like, "Oh, she just fell?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, good. Oh, that's good.
That's great.
I'm glad she fell."
-Yeah.
-Now, old people falling --
I never --
I don't see old people falling.
I always see the aftermath.
-Yeah.
-I don't think anyone
ever sees old people fall.
You just see them
being tended to afterward.
And it usually -- they
just look shocked like this.
Like [panting]
[ Laughter ]
Like, just total bewilderment.
And like --
and you kind of get the look,
like, you get, they're like,
"Should I even get up?
[ Laughter ]
Is it even worth it anymore?"
-I think you might not
see them fall
'cause I think they fall
so slowly.
-Yeah. Maybe I'm passing
old people falling constantly.
And I don't even --
I'm not even aware of it.
Remotely.
-There's a photo.
A photo of us from
years ago at a party.
-This is proof you're having --
you had your second kid.
-Yeah.
-I'm still single.
-Yeah. We are the same age.
-Yes. We have different --
We've had different luck
in romance.
-Uh-huh.
-It may be my fault.
[ Laughter ]
You present better than I do.
-I don't think that's true.
-You're more charismatic
than me.
-You're very charismatic.
-Tell me about it.
But I'm saying...
[ Laughter ]
I'm saying, you're a little
more charismatic than me.
And this is a photo
from a nightclub in 2004.
-Mm-hmm.
-This is why Seth
is happily married
with two children
and I am still on Instagram.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
We'll let the audience judge.
-Yes.
-Who is -- because maybe it's
in the eye of the beholder.
Maybe people look at this
and be like,
"I think Neal is the charismatic
one in this photo."
Okay, here we go.
-Start close on Seth.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's get a little tighter.
Can we get a little tighter?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. That's a real, like --
me being, like,
I'm talking to a girl and being,
like,
"Oh, does your friend
want to meet my friend?
He's...not here."
[ Laughter ]
-We were bad being single
because we would --
The only thing -- we would
just go up to women
and might as well go, like,
"Hey, you like skits?"
Because you were like a low --
You were just starting to get
good at "Saturday Night Live."
-Yeah.
-And I was starting to get --
-So all we would do
is we would go to bars
and we'd talk about
comedy writing.
And then we would assume
that any women
who were nearby us
also wanted to know.
-You're like, "What's that?
Act breaks?"
[ Laughter ]
-"Were you gentlemen talking
about the rule of threes?"
-Yeah. Yeah.